[Music]
thank you
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show where it
is my job to deconstruct world-class
performers across many many disciplines
my guest today I'm so happy to have him
is Bill Gurley you can find him on
Twitter at B Gurley that's g-u-r-l-e-y
bill has spent more than 20 years as a
general partner at Benchmark before
entering the Venture Capital business
Bill spent four years on Wall Street as
a top-ranked research analyst including
three years at Credit Suisse first
Boston Bill also maintains a Blog on the
evolution and economics of high
technology businesses called above the
crowd which you can find at
abovethecrowd.com over his Venture
career he has worked with such companies
as GrubHub next door open table stitch
fix Uber and Zillow among many others
bill has BS in computer science from the
University of Florida and an MBA from
the University of Texas he's also
chartered financial analyst bill is a
board trustee at the Santa Fe Institute
a research and education center focused
on the study and understanding of
complex adaptive systems Bill nice to
see you thanks for making the time
thanks for having me all right so I
wanted to start with a number of things
that I've seen pop up repeatedly
in various forms in doing prep for this
conversation and the first I wanted to
get your take on and expansion on is
Michael Porter's book competitive
strategy subtitle techniques for
analyzing Industries and competitors
which you have described I believe as
the most efficient short form MBA that
one can find could you please explain
what this book is and if you still hold
that opinion why you hold that opinion
yeah I mean this is if if you do go to
get an MBA like in the first semester or
whatever they usually make you take a
corporate strategy course and it's the
first book assigned it's like extremely
well known business books there's a
belief in Silicon Valley
that that an MBA is worthless and people
[__] on it all the time yeah right yet I
would say 80 or 90 of the entrepreneurs
I meet would benefit greatly by reading
the first three chapters of this book
and it's really just about trying to
understand the Dynamics of Industry one
of the most common mistakes
entrepreneurs make is they come up with
some kind of technological breakthrough
in their own mind
but they don't spend any time analyzing
the industry structure or whether the go
to market is going to be possible or not
and the book just has a wonderful
framework for thinking about the
competitive dynamics of an industry and
whether or not you'd be able to break in
or be successful or maintain success
this actually
makes me think more broadly of
Frameworks and recipes as it were
for making decisions so back in the day
you were a sell side analyst and I would
love for you to Define what that is and
also just Define buy side versus sell
side and
at that time at one point at least the
top three analysts covering the PC
industry retired and I'm reading from a
transcript on medium Dan Benton David
chorus if I'm correctly pronouncing that
and Charlie wolf and then Charlie became
the advisor for young analysts so you
got to work with him here's the part
that's of interest to me so Dana David
became friends so they both gave me all
of their financial models and I'm
curious what they gave you what were
those models yeah and do you still use
any of those models no no no so they
were taught me specific but let me let
me start with the cell versus buy so and
the industry has changed over the years
but
a cell site analyst is someone who does
research on behalf of an investment bank
that is presumably going to make money
from trading on their trading desk that
someone sends your way because they
valued the research so you're providing
research to help sell stocks like that's
how you're going to get paid the buy
side is anyone at a mutual fund who's
trading for their own account so if
you're a if you're a buy site analyst
you don't publish like it doesn't get
public because you're using that as
proprietary information the the sell
side stuff gets broadcasts broadly and
usually when someone changes estimates
or you hear about a ratings change
that's usually a sell site analyst that
has made made a decision to change
something and that's what ends up on
CNBC and so a cell site analysis is
going to sound very naive but a
sell-side analyst could make a
recommendation to buy right they could
make a recommendation like a strong buy
recommendation or a strong sell or
somewhere in between the two yeah that's
I think where where my Long Island brand
was was having trouble yeah
because the bank makes money in multiple
ways and they question whether people
are biased or not and then you had the
whole Henry Blodgett thing from the 2000
period
so it's complicated and could you
describe I know that you don't at this
point use them any longer but the
company specific models what were the
models that they provided I was super
fortunate in my entire career by being
in places where Windows opened up that I
was able to take advantage of but the
situation you described I landed on Wall
Street very fortunately started covering
an industry and there's a magazine
called Institutional Investor that pulls
the buy side and ranks the analyst and
the top three analysts in the category
and it all retired within one year and
they all became friends
partially from my own networking like I
was reaching out to them but the models
they shared were the models they had
built on the companies we all covered so
their own particular version of Dell's
financials or compact or Microsoft and
so it just helped me have a better
understanding I could see what they did
that kind of thing
got it what I'm trying to unpack also
through the course of this conversation
is just how you think about
models and making decisions I find that
interesting so this is hopping around a
little bit but you did not pursue Google
as an investment in 2002
and
you had some investing rules of thumb in
place and I suppose what I'm wondering
is how you think about rules as an
investor in the sense that it seems like
perhaps to be consistently great you
need rules but if you have rules you're
inevitably going to miss some great
opportunities but perhaps that's okay
how do you think about rules like was
was missing Google the result of a flaw
in the set of rules that you had at the
time or was it just sort of a a
collateral
Miss let me work my way back to it
because it's clearly the biggest mistake
of my career so I it's something I
thought about a lot
yeah so I think any investor starts with
just building bedrock and that comes
from reading and there's a ton of books
in history you can read you can go
through you know all the Buffett letters
as an example you know you can read
Peter Lynch's one up on Wall Street
there's my good friend Mike mobison has
put out some amazing books that are a
lot more nuanced about stock prices that
kind of thing a random walk down Wall
Street by Burton McHale and and then you
build your bedrock and then you know
you're out there and you're looking for
an opportunity so I think public stocks
are a little different than Venture but
there's some overlap but you're looking
for you know a reality that you think is
going to emerge that's not priced into
the stock so that requires you both to
know or to think you know where the
world's going and also to know what the
expectations are currently embedded in
the stock because if you just have the
same opinion it's already embedded
you're not going to make any money
there's a great piece by Howard marks
where he talks about you have to be act
you have to be right and contrarian you
know you can't just be right you have to
be right and contrarian and that's more
difficult there's a famous saying that
I'm sure has been uttered on your
podcast before the kind of strong
opinions loosely held and yes I think I
think all investors have to work within
that framework because things change
there's many many variables
none of them are constant they're all
Dynamic and the minute you set a very
hard rule then you might be setting
yourself up for a mistake
and Venture I have found is a world
where that happens frequently and so the
the Google example you know and it's
really important to say that we didn't
lay Chase like they presented there were
25 employees later in Sergey presented
they presented to him I'm sure a whole
bunch of firms and we didn't lay Chase
we should have played Chase but we
didn't you know at the time
Yahoo was at ten dollars down from like
80 excite was going bankrupt so search
didn't look that exciting from an
external viewpoint
you had two PhD Founders who had never
been a CEO before and were insistent
they were going to be good as a CEO
normally that's a red flag you know two
PhD founders
and there was there was just a number of
things where you would make a list and
say oops you know this probably isn't
isn't what you want to do now I'd like
to highlight and I always do the two
best Venture capitalists in the world at
the time John door Mike Moritz
kind of locked hands and said yes right
and so it'd be it'd be erroneous for me
to say like oh if you were you know a
well-studied venture capitalist you
obviously get to know at that point in
time because the two best didn't and and
I think it's just the subtlety of the
game
there's a there's a great reality
Adventure that a lot of people talk
about now but you can only lose one time
your money and yeah in a case like
Google you make what ten thousand times
your money and that asymmetric result
means you have to bias towards positive
in a situation like that because the
odds are just ridiculously different
yeah and so what should have happened is
I remember one of my partners looking at
Larry and saying what does it take to
get this deal done right now because he
was a closer he was a closer type and
Larry said 120 pre and we should have
said how about 150. like if I could go
back
if I could go back but you can't go back
deal got done at like 80. so below what
Larry had had told us but still
obviously historic so how did you then
revise your rules of thumb or rules
moving forward after that if it all like
is a case like that granted it turned
into what Google is now
so it's easy to maybe punish yourself
for not not laying Chase but how did
things change after that you know after
that like the firm did Twitter Snapchat
Uber
you know we got some right you know
after yeah you did yeah and around that
time I remember we used to give a book
out to our LPS our limited partners our
investors at every annual meeting and I
think Bruce had just read the rational
Optimist which is a Matt Ridley book and
he started using a phrase at our partner
meeting what could go right
and because of this asymmetric outcome
thing where you could make ten thousand
times your money and only lose once on
the downside it was the right frame of
mind so like
it's very easy to get into a trap
Adventure where getting no right feels
like a win and it's just not yet I mean
obviously you can't do every deal you
know you can't do every investment you
go broke but like getting overly jazzed
about correctly you know
identifying a negative or a no like it's
just not that big a deal it's not the
job the job is to find the outliers so
my experience granted it's it's limited
in some respects but my experience and
perception of benchmarks you guys are
more selective than a lot of venture
capital firms and a lot of angels who
maybe like the poker player who doesn't
mind his or her bankroll like yes you
can only use one extra money but if you
do lose all of your money
The Jig Is up right like you know that's
the problem with the complete opposite
Theory you can't just do every
investment you make yeah we have another
challenge Tim which is weave for a
variety of reasons have chosen a
strategy where we don't let our money
walk around without our work product and
and our involvement and so right we go
on a board if we make an investment and
we usually become the largest
shareholder on the board and as a result
our limitation is our board seats more
than the capital actually but at this
time you can't do 20 of them not well
yeah
so you mentioned Howard marks oak tree
Capital who's been on the podcast twice
very very impressive fellas I've seen
you mention two investors I'm sure
you've mentioned more but two have come
up repeatedly in various interviews and
so on Howard marks and Stan
druckenmiller could you please speak to
what makes them impressive or
interesting to you
sometime in the last four or five years
when interest rates wouldn't get away
from zero for so long I told myself I
have to learn more about macro because I
just know nothing and it's causing all
kind of problems in my industry I had
been reading Howard's work for years one
one of the things I just love about
people like Howard and Buffett does it
but like people who who
archive their thought process just as
part of their own process but it's quite
kind if you're if you're a Learner in
the field to have someone of that
capability that insist upon you know
writing these letters and making them
public which they've done I started
reading Howard's work when I was on the
sell side 25 years ago and I've gotten
to know him now and he's he's in
addition to being very very bright he's
also just a wonderful human and fun to
interact with
there aren't many people if you study
Financial history if you taught most
people in Buffett included will tell you
macro is impossible like you shouldn't
even try and the two the two individuals
you mentioned are are two of the only
ones that are known for being successful
and macro investing powered mostly by
being one of the most successful and
longest tenured investor in the bond
market and stand for taking more kind of
single individual bets
that are macro in nature going back to
his success
with Soros
he's become kind of refamous in the past
12 months
for predicting the inflation situation
we're in and being very loud about it
could you if you don't mind just give a
definition it could be simple of macro
investing for people who may not know
that term if you go to the business
school
there's two economic Clash you can take
microeconomics and macroeconomics
microeconomics is a lot about what's
discussed in competitive strategy the
Michael Porter book so it's it's about
the interaction between firms within an
industry pricing
that kind of thing competitive Dynamics
macro is the study of economies you know
writ large and I'm fascinated with
complex systems our economy is certainly
one of those things as is whether and
whatnot which is why I've gotten
involved with Santa Fe Institute
but they're nearly impossible to predict
and yeah it's where you get into real
real trouble there might be a variable
you're not tracking that has never
flipped from zero to one and when it
does flip from zero to one all your
models all your planning you know are
out the window because this other
thing's different this time and you can
I mean it's why no one can predict the
weather more than five days in in front
of us right because it's just too
Dynamic and too complex and most people
feel that way about about macro let me
go back in time a little bit
revisiting the the sell side analyst
side of things so
I believe at one point and I could be
getting the terminology wrong but you
were an Institutional Investor which you
already mentioned Institutional Investor
All-American or All-America research
team Parts because those three people
left the field but yes
what allows someone to land on that list
so it's a poll of your customers it's a
poll of the buy side so they literally
pull the buy side in each industry and
say who was most helpful
I will tell you that and I don't know
this probably came from some book I read
in business school but when I showed up
and this is this is a
framework someone could use but when I
showed up on
on Wall Street in one of the very first
weekly meetings they introduced us to
this to the sales force the sales force
is the individual at your firm
responsible for that account for
Fidelity for Wellington for teachers you
know of Texas or whatever and and they
own the relationship and somewhere in my
youthful wisdom I decided to ask each
salesperson is there one client that
will spend 30 to 45 minutes with me as a
new analyst and just tell me what they
want like I'm just gonna ask them
questions I'm not I'm not gonna have
anything for them I just want to know
how I can serve them best and I did like
20 of those interviews
before I had started the job
that's a roundabout answer to how do you
get on the list because I knew what they
were looking for at that point in time
what made you a good analyst and let me
explain why I'm asking I'm asking
because one of the advantages that you
bring to a board which you've already
discussed right the two Board of a
startup in the art of company building
is your in-depth understanding of how
the public markets work and if a company
is aiming for going public and so on you
have knowledge that scares a lot of
other folks who might
intimidates
or befuddles a lot of folks who might
otherwise want to be on the board
so I'm curious to know what made you a
good analyst the thing I learned in
those interviews
both in terms of the because I would
also ask him who does a really good job
of this and then if I could I'd try and
befriend that person but what I heard
frequently back was look and this is a
little different from what the world
perceives you know I don't really need
you to make this buy or sell
recommendation like that's not what I
what I would really get a huge benefit
from is if you provide a point of view
or a piece of analysis that causes us to
think differently about a particular
company or industry like can you go off
and do some work that then other people
haven't thought of that causes us to
question that makes us want to talk to
you and and hear what you're thinking
and so that became really the essence of
of what I was focused on in and
partially from listening to them and
partially from mimicking and copying
David course who you mentioned
I started doing a weekly
facts at the time
and David was doing that before he quit
and so I started doing it too and
interestingly the Wall Street firm tries
to keep your
content closed within their customer set
and this is not very loyal to my firm
but it became very obvious to me that a
sell side analyst that was more well
known
was more powerful more impactful and so
I
intentionally started expanding the
distribution of this weekly pieces as
far and wide as I could
how did you expand that distribution
I would leverage the sales force and get
them to give me fax numbers you know
that's that's where I started
I then you know started developing
industry relationships which is
important because you're covering these
companies you start going to investor
days
the buy side is talking to these
companies as well and so I started
getting some of them on board
and then
probably the most successful hack of my
career
happened when I was invited to attend
Stewart House Subs agenda conference
which I think was in Phoenix at the time
it used to be it was the conference
everyone went to so Gates would be in
the front row Allison would be there
they would stay for the whole thing you
could walk up and talk to him Michael
Dell was there like everyone was there
how many analysts were invited to such
an event I don't know if Charlie had
been invited and Charlie Got Me In
and I don't even remember you know Rick
sherlin was probably there he's a famous
Microsoft analyst
and you know it's kind of what code is
today but the difference back then way
back then was the most famous founder
CEO set through the whole thing and were
available the whole time today if one of
them speaking they come in the back door
they go on stage they leave like they're
not around you know so it was pretty
cool
what was the hack at the conference so
this was around the time where the Palm
Pilot launched and so in the lobby of
the conference was
they were selling them they weren't free
they were selling a Palm Pilot and I
think it was like 200 300 I can't
remember but they had put the contact
information for every attendee at the
conference in the Palm Pilot and so I
ran some quick math
people weren't really doing like cost of
customer acquisition back then but I
think it was like
70 cents a name or something like that
of the most influential people in the
entire tech industry and so I bought the
Palm pie that I took it home and I
spammed the four or 500 most important
people in the tech industry with my
Weekly Newsletter
did you end up developing
close or closer relationships with any
of them because of that newsletter I
think so and I think also just a
reputation it's actually not that
surprising today right there's plenty of
content influencers all over the place
now with sub stack and everything it was
just a version of that when there
weren't as many people doing it right it
started with facts and became email and
today I just mostly tweeted I don't
force the distribution out of these
other things anymore
and I'm not as frequent but but yeah I
mean it's a common
way to build reputation in a network and
you do this with your own life so yeah I
do I do
so let's come back to the the point you
made of helping your clients
think differently yeah right presenting
them as something that helps them to
think differently and I'd like to
connect that to a story I'd love you to
tell which is about
what you learned from a food analyst and
the question that might come before that
is how did you meet the food analyst
like why were you even having a
conversation well first of all all the
analysts share a floor so we're all
physically proximate so the person that
covers food or telcos or electric
utilities we're all in the same group
and the firm had efforts underway which
Charlie wolf ended up running to try and
educate the analysts in a common
framework or whatever so that we would
all be better at what we do and that
kind of thing and
for reasons that I I mean I guess birds
of a feather flock together for reasons
I don't remember me and Michael Morrison
the food analyst started spending a lot
of time together and we're still close
friends today he's involved at Santa Fe
and and I see him frequently
and he's done amazing things himself and
released several books and and he's
quite well known
yeah so we started hanging out together
he had just read a bunch of books on a
framework called return on investing
Capital which Stern Steward published on
McKenzie had a book called valuation
they still do
that uses this type of analysis and he
was he was spreading it was the word
proselytizing yeah through the analyst
group and you know I was a sponge at
that point in time so I said sure so I
took the framework and ran it on all of
my companies it turned out just
by happenstance that Dell stood out like
a sore thumb with ridiculously high roic
numbers versus the rest of the industry
like night and day like 20 to one wasn't
even close and in fact it was so
ridiculous like the first time I showed
him he didn't Michael didn't believe it
was true and so we got in the numbers
and that kind of thing and there's
probably like 10 super lucky things that
happened in my life but him giving me
that framework and then at the exact
same time Dell as a company had made two
stumbles they had an options trade that
went bad and their laptops had caught on
fire and so the stock was in in the
ditch it was trading six times earnings
and we had discovered if you will
through this framework that they had a
massive competitive Advantage because of
this return on invested Capital thing
and so we went to a strong Buy on a
broken stock and it went up 100x in the
public markets from there and I became
close friends with Michael and and Tom
Meredith who was CFO at the time they
did all the work I I was just along for
the ride but it was very fortunate
but that helped put Bill Gurley on the
map in the same way that maybe eBay
really thrust Benchmark into the
Limelight very much so especially with
the buy Side Community
so Michael there's a chance I've read a
book of his did he write a book called
think twice harnessing the power of
counter intuition four or five books and
he's got great content he did a Google
talk that's on YouTube that I'd highly
recommend people watch it's just
fascinating he's been on a Shaughnessy a
couple times so yeah he's worth checking
out so in that particular case of
proselytizing
did Michael do that was he proselytizing
and sharing this roic
idea because he had peers who were
non-competitive and it was sort of a
deposit in the karmic bank account to
hopefully have some reciprocation or is
he just a nice guy it just seems like
the environment that would not be true
in all environments right that someone
would take this new insight and share it
widely I think he's a natural learner
and maybe that's what you would
attribute
Howard Mark's writing to you know you
ask people who do that you know yes
Buffett why do you write your letters
like I think people believe that it
helps their mental Frameworks if they
write stuff down and it challenges them
even in when I write a blog post from
the minute I have an idea or a
compulsion to say hey I'm going to write
about this topic the process through
which you actually put the words to
paper and structure the paragraphs
structure the argument you know you get
smarter sometimes you decide oops I was
wrong like you learn by putting it all
together and Michael's always been that
way he's pretty much built a career out
of being someone who studies companies
valuation Frameworks how investors win I
mean he's gone deep on things like
Myers-Briggs on different investors and
like structural how do you organize an
investment Team all kinds of stuff like
that and it's what fascinates him and
he's a synthesizer so
I think some of the best non-fiction
writers or synthesizers people say oh
you know Michael Porter competitive
strategy 14 other people had written
that stuff before well he wrote it in a
really compact way that's easy to read
that's super helpful and Michael does
that yeah he goes out and reads the
stuff that's super hard to read it's
overly academic or whatnot and packages
in a way that people can consume
I remember Kevin Kelly said to me once
and I'm paraphrasing but I really enjoy
Kevin Kelly for people who don't know uh
look him up kk.org and he was saying
I don't write to express what I think I
write in order to think or discover what
I think or clarify what I think so the
taking of the roic from in this case
let's just say food and applying it to
Dell was this sort of translational move
so I want to read something from I think
this was a Vox interview
and uh you can't believe everything you
read on the internet but it would make
sense so this is related to OpenTable so
having come out of OpenTable being
successful this is quoting you I was
trying to think of other Industries
where if you put a network on top of it
it would absorb waste and make it more
efficient and more usable and this is
within the context of of looking for
something that would
basically appear like uber right so not
working within a taxi framework but with
black cars and I'm just curious where
else you've applied that type of
translation where you see a
case study or a a successful proof right
of a network being laid on top of
something and then applying it to
something else are there other examples
of translating in that way absolutely
and by the way our impetus to do
OpenTable is based upon something like
that so in 1996 Brian Arthur who was at
the Santa Fe Institute back then
published in an article in Harvard
Business review
called increasing returns in the Two
Worlds of business and it was really the
first piece that talked about Network
effects of course Microsoft was already
starting to really take off but this
idea of network effects is that you know
some industry is going to be structured
where you get win or take most and the
more successful you are you get locked
in yep and Brian talked about things
just like the Microsoft uis like you
know how word works you get comfortable
with how it works and then like
switching has cost and those kind of
things and sharing documents
collaboration and
you know Zoom obviously has massive
Network effects so we started looking
for those things because they tend to
cause outlier
outcomes
so I can remember and this gets ended
back to your rule stuff when I met with
Chuck tempson the founder of OpenTable
you know and he had three restaurants
you had to believe a lot to get from
that point to the global phenomena that
it became and the bet that we talked
about making when we said okay let's go
do this thing is
if we get enough if we get enough
restaurants on this thing then the
consumers will come and if the consumers
come then people will have to get on and
that's what happened but you had to
believe it because otherwise you know at
the time we were selling PCS to
restaurant owners and guess what they
didn't they didn't have connectivity at
the time so we had to partner with
someone to get like Broadband installed
which wasn't easy I mean it was all bad
so your normal rule set we're putting a
piece of Hardware in a small to medium
business that didn't have a lot of money
and we had to provision a Broadband so
you would normally go don't do that but
I remember my my favorite proof point of
that Network effect and then I'll get to
some of the other models at one point
we were reviewing the Salesforce
productivity and and our model
when we scaled up the business said we
had our each salesperson had to close
four restaurants a month and at the time
we were up to 7.7 so we're feeling
pretty good things were starting to
break our way and in the board meeting
they laid out the list of all the sales
people and one of them had done 35 35
restaurants in a month and so I asked
the question who is that salesperson and
you know we started over table started
in San Francisco and we we played local
game we didn't go everywhere at once we
built liquidity City by City anyway that
sales person was the one sales person
left in San Francisco where we had 90
penetration and so the 35 came we're
coming out of that last ten and that
individual was basically taking orders
and that to me was like oh yeah the
network effects really working here yeah
and so anyway we look for that some
other Frameworks SAS could I actually
pause for one second before you get to
SAS so you talked about you have to
believe you mentioned you have to
believe a lot of things can go right in
order to invest in a business like
OpenTable at the time
I would love to know what contributed to
your ability to have
conviction I mean how much of it was
potential Network effects versus total
addressable Market versus founder versus
other stuff I would say in some of these
verticals both open table and Uber there
were years and years and years where
everyone thought the Tam was too small
yep in fact oh here's a great story this
was in 99 so this is a 23 year old story
but I successfully recruited a CFO from
a public company which you could do back
in those Glory Days
to Come into OpenTable and one day I
showed up early for a board meeting in
and the CFO comes to me and he says Bill
I'm I'm gonna quit and I said
okay I go why are you gonna quit and he
goes this business will never work and I
said okay well I will never work and he
says well my model says it'll never work
so I said show me your model so we look
at the model and I dive in and he has
frozen penetration in each City at 17
and he had come from a retail business
and I Go why'd you freeze it at 17 he
said
oh no one gets more than 17 market share
all the businesses I've worked with
because I believe the network effects I
was like we're going to get 99. like
we're not stopping at 17 we're gonna get
99 you don't understand how this is
going to work and you know that's
because I believe the network effects
and he didn't yeah and when we filed the
S1 I really wanted the FedEx did you
stay or did he leave oh he left he quit
and I decided not to FedEx in the S1 I
figured he had seen it but by then we
were kicking off you know massive cash
flow each quarter yeah sure so you're
talking about models and I interrupted
you you were going to jump to SAS yeah I
was just going to mention a bunch of
them yeah please I did my first SAS deal
in 99 and that that category of
companies is still bearing fruit like
people have made tons of money you know
and now it's common but but at the time
it wasn't and you transformed an entire
industry open source you know benchmarks
probably had I don't know eight or nine
successful open source companies where
you've used that model to attack
a industry that's pre-existing but where
someone has proprietary technology
social networks I mean we're fortunate
to be in Twitter Snapchat Instagram and
Matt Kohler who is a partner at
Benchmark developed kind of a sixth
sense on what a breakout social network
looks like and we've had a few that
missed too I mean but the outsized
nature of the winds are so high yeah so
there's like four or five different ones
right that we look for Network effects
you know sort of like and you get good
at you start to understand what works
what doesn't what leads to success what
doesn't I mean there's nuances right
like in open source
with that business model which is you're
basically packaging support and
reliability
because someone could just download it
for free so how do you charge if you and
this goes back to Michael Porter but if
you have a very Consolidated industry of
big companies they don't pay they just
hire the people that know how to use the
product so we were in MySQL as an
example Google and Yahoo are two of the
biggest customers never paid us a penny
you need that product to go into the
corporate world where people want that
kind of hand holding and that's where
you get paid so you can't just be oh I
love open source because then you get
into something where it's serving a much
more finite set of customers and then
you can't make the model work so you
have to learn the the esoteric nuances
but anyway yeah there are many veins and
Venture that get mined over and over and
over again if they're big enough
this is maybe a novice question but I'm
curious what rules did you guys have
around bet sizing right to use those uh
yeah maybe a poker analogy how do you
think about
the parameters around the size of the
check that you cut just in terms of
long-term strategy and benchmarks are
very particular firm we've wandered off
course a couple times but we've always
come back to our kind of home base and
we've we've remained committed and
focused to very early stage investing
and we're pretty much Market takers on
what that first check size is what do
you mean by that there's a competitive
dynamic in the industry that kind of
defines what a series a check looks like
or sometimes series B and if we thought
something was going to be an outsized
winner we wouldn't miss it because
Market was saying that had to be 15 or
five
it's more like a ticket right we're
buying 15 or five you're talking about
15 or 5 million yeah right so would the
guiding principle in a case like that be
the percentage of ownership that you
would end up with yeah something we care
way more about than the size of the
check yeah and we're not the only one a
lot of venture firms operate that way
yeah sure so board seat is the
constraint and then ownership is the
optimization variable
whatever the math is that follows out of
that is is what you think so to be right
and contrarian I mean I guess sometimes
in Venture I'm not sure if
I'm curious how you cultivate that in
partner meetings like what do those what
is the format of a successful partner
meeting when someone's getting up and
saying well one thing I would here's my
deal offer as a preamble to at least our
process is the founding partners of
Benchmark did something that was not
hadn't been done before in Venture which
is they created an equal partnership and
most business Partnerships and this
includes private equity and and law
firms and and real estate firms there's
a hierarchy and the people that have
been there the longest sit at the very
top and they take an outsized amount and
some of our founding Partners had worked
at those firms and felt like the young
people did more of the work and
therefore you know it wasn't conducive
to the right type of internal Behavior
so they created this notion of an equal
partnership and even today when we go
hire a new partner they come in and they
have an equal seat at the table we just
divide the pi
which is very different the reason I
think that's important to any discussion
about our own processes is I think that
has a number of dynamics that kind of
emerge from being equal I think
everyone's voice is heard whereas if you
had a hierarchical firm and the big boss
walked in and said blah blah blah like
that would carry so much more weight
right yeah so you feel like your voice
is heard when you come in
I think we root for one another if I'm
at a hierarchical firm that's up or out
I'm kind of competing with my peers yep
here because we're going to divide it
equally I want our new partners to be as
successful as I possibly can and I felt
that on the way in and I feel the desire
to do it on the way out those are just
natural emergent properties
so then to come around to your question
like how do you be contrarian how do you
have well I mentioned like we we have
this phrase what could go right like
you're just constantly
thinking Devil's Advocate in your mind
right and Devil's Advocate on the
positive side like what would it take
for this thing to break out like are we
making a mistake could this could you
imagine this being really really big and
what would have to happen
for that to happen when someone new
comes along you'd be surprised I have
specific memories of new partners coming
in and we'll just tell them bring all
the companies you meet in like just
bring them in and
those companies will present and then we
talk about them afterwards and that's a
partner meeting yeah and that's where
the learning process gets passed down
I'm sure just like storytelling in a
tribe 300 years ago or 400 years ago
right like that that is that Dynamic and
it's weird the you know a lot of people
say Venture is at the end of the day a
pattern recognition job but we also
talked about those rules can get you in
trouble so you're trying to create these
kind of loose pattern recognition so
that you can be helpful and identify
things and then you want to pass those
along and then you got to constantly
check it you know because of what we
said about how you can miss something
but when that new partner comes in and
those are happening I can remember and I
leave the names out but
one of the new partners that he brought
in company one no company two no he's
like he's very frustrated and then
company 10 he brought in we were like
try and close that immediately like like
just the complete opposite and he
remembers that too but it like you're
you're starting to learn you're starting
to pick up the collective wisdom of the
group
and it is a bit of an art form because
in that window between when you meet a
company and when you might try and close
the investment I bet you the average is
under 60 days oh yeah yeah yeah for sure
it might be closer to three weeks and so
It All Happened super fast
was there any feedback that you recall
or could just hypothetically imagine you
gave that new partner that helped him or
her to hone in on the 10th that was then
a yes closes immediately A lot of it
goes back to what you might pick up in
competitive strategy the two books that
I would put for the Venture Community
for the startup community that I'd put
as Next Level right on top of
competitive strategy or innovators
dilemma which does an amazing job of
describing why startups can compete with
big companies amazing and crossing the
chasm which does a really good job of
explaining how a startup should kind of
sequence their customer base as they as
they grow and they're both fundamental
and you just pick up a number of these
different things I'll give you an
example because you start to develop
intuition so a company where we had a
quick yes on that I'm on is called
hacker one at the time of hacker one's
founding there were four companies that
used white hat hackers to make their
sites more secure Microsoft Google
Facebook and Mozilla they were the only
four no one else did it and yet
people would say I remember seeing an
interview with Cheryl Sandberg where she
said someone asked her about privacy and
security and she says well the best
thing we have is this bug Bounty program
and she talks about it for a while in
the crowd applauds one of the
individuals that worked on the Facebook
program
came up with a business idea of why
don't we build this for the other
companies in the universe like every
other company in the universe and when
they present it everyone like we didn't
even discuss the company the minute they
left we were like okay how are we going
to close this like everyone had just
jumped to yes because it seemed so
tautological there's no way this thing's
great for these four companies and no
one else yeah and it turned out that
those four companies had a group of like
20 or 30 people running a program which
other companies couldn't do so it was
just natural that if you ran that as a
service people would would jump in
so that's one that we got too fast
so you've mentioned a number of your
partners
Matt caller who is was also very helpful
for the for Uber seems to be very good
at
using himself as the guinea pig very
smart guy uh what are some of the
lessons you've learned from your
partners and that could be anyone Fenton
Lasky Kohler would don't even
necessarily have to mention names I'm
just curious what their superpowers are
or what you have
adapted learned from them
I'd probably go back to some of the
founding partners because those were the
ones that I learned from one of them I'd
say from Bruce Dunleavy is just have a
really big tent like we're in a
networking business where you're trying
to look under every Rock for the next
possible deal and cutting off Avenues of
information or flow is just a really
stupid idea and so it ties in with what
could go right but just be super
open-minded and so Bruce had been
involved with a company that I think was
in a software tool space the Name
Escapes me but we could look it up
and had developed a lot of friendships
with down
the organizational
chart at the company and one day one of
the engineers from that company comes to
him and says I'm working on this
Marketplace thing called eBay
and he was from a different industry but
because he had developed that
relationship that came in now it turned
out that Bob Cagle was much more excited
about eBay than Bruce was and so Bruce
made that intro because we're equal
partnership that's all cool and Bob ends
up doing the deal and you know becomes
the number one rank VC in the land but
it all came from that relationship so
big tent the older I get I just take the
time be kind you know be available it
pays off at least in our industry it
pays off big time so that's one another
one is just and this is more specific to
venture but unless you're super lucky
there are two VCS I know that were very
fortunate Kohler and
roll off it's quite roll off with
YouTube and Matt with Instagram where
they had a hit like two years in but for
the vast majority of venture capitalists
they don't have a liquidity event until
year eight or nine and so it's easy to
doubt yourself
and three years in people like to use
the child age analogy you've got
12 year olds becoming 13 year olds and
your whole portfolios like that with
acne all over their face and you can
really lose confidence and so one thing
that a lot of my partners did was just
like it's gonna be okay get back out
there you're doing fine you know that
kind of thing which was way more helpful
than you could possibly imagine because
the anxiety yeah was like spiking
I want to come back to open source in a
minute but first I'm wondering you've
mentioned a number of books that are
sort of broadly applicable to
entrepreneurship and I'm sure translate
to as you mentioned investing in a
number of capacities
if you were advising someone or just
mentoring someone who wanted to learn
how to be a good angel investor or
venture capitalist in Tech
what might you suggest to them in terms
of approach or resources books anything
I'll give you a few more books and then
obviously the world's different today
the content consumption is is so
different but
there's a book I love called startup by
Kaplan I think yeah I bought that when I
first moved to Silicon Valley in 99 that
was one of the very first books yeah
it's just fantastic and he was in the
way they call that world because it's
where General magic was it was like the
first
portable computers like every one of
them failed yeah every one of these but
they all raised massive amounts of money
he on his ride home every day had a
cassette tape and left like an archive
or a diary which makes the book so good
because the details fantastic but they
had the best venture capitalist they had
the best advisors they had the best
Executives and the executives that were
in this was go Corp I think that were
there all went on to do amazing things
but this company failed hard failed hard
and I think it's nice to combine a book
of failure with all the books of success
yeah I just think it's super educational
interestingly if you read that you
should probably also simultaneously
watch the general magic documentary it's
so good yeah because they were a
competitor with goat and the same story
and the people there all went on to to
Wild success
yeah it's like the yodoworski's Dune
where Geiger who went on to create the
iconic design for alien and Aliens I
mean they're just these these failures
that contain
an All-Star team and fail for any number
of factors but General magic I just want
to second that recommendation if people
want an additional inside look listen to
my interview with Tony Fidel which goes
into great depth on that on Tony I'd
read his new book build it's solid it's
very strong it's got a lot of Frameworks
and you can agree with them or not agree
with them but I do think entrepreneurs
benefit from Frameworks because just
running by the seat of your pants like
you need you need a framework for having
weekly meetings you need a framework for
executive recruiting you need a
framework for development of your team
and there are a lot of good ones there's
probably 20 good ones of each of those
but the worst thing you can possibly do
is have no framework and just kind of
see to your pants and by the way that's
the most frequent solution the
absolutely no no framework I would
mention shoe dog I don't know if the
reality had as many near-death
experiences as the book makes it sound
like but it's it's good to see the
tenacity you need this is the Phil
Knight Nike book yeah the tenacity you
need to make it is high and so if you're
starting a company because you think
it's going to be a good lifestyle holy
[__] you're in for a rude awakening yeah
so the same writer who penned shoe dog
in reality is the same person who did
open the autobiography of Agassi which
is another spectacular and apparently
the new Harry book oh no kidding yeah
all right that's a selling point because
I think it's moringer is
spectacular he's fantastic okay so shoe
dog so so far these are company building
yeah books which is totally valid of
course we're kind of high-tech macro if
there is such a thing I think Ridley's
two books the rational optimists and how
Innovation Works are just fantastic and
spectacular they're much higher level
but they're really really good what
makes them good
the first book Ridley has this point of
view that I think is very hard to
dispute that the vast majority of wealth
creation and increase of standard of
living for humans on the planet come
from two things Commerce and ideas what
he calls ideas having sex so if someone
comes up with a new farming technique
the marginal cost of that is zero and if
you pass it along to someone their
productivity improves and so it's super
powerful in my mind especially when I
think about people a lot of people on
the planet want to improve standard
living with a lot of people and I look
at
what
ding Xiaoping did in China and say I
don't know that any other human in the
history of the world has unlocked as
much standard of living increase as this
one human you know by bringing
capitalism to China and it's something
that really speaks to me yeah much
smaller scale but people should study
Lee Kuan Yew okay in this whole
Singapore just the whole Singapore Story
I mean basically taking it from a swamp
to what it is today is just an
incredible I agree on the dangsha pink
piece yeah yeah and so then on other
content like the world's way different
now right with podcasts and blogs and
Twitter and all these kind of things so
no matter what you're doing but
especially if you want to do Venture
attack like there's lots of people that
talk their book that talk their game
like follow listen read consume consume
read read read read like I don't think
you can get too much information let's
segue it up to open source what else do
you think open source might be able to
solve and I've had some reasonably
direct experience with watching I
suppose one example of what you
described which is automatic and very
good friend Matt mullenweg I'm an
advisor to automatic and for those who
don't know Matt has been on the show
multiple times was a lead developer of
Wordpress very familiar with open source
and then has built
a sort of services and Enterprise grade
secure stable solution for for many
different businesses and people in the
form of automatic
so I'm deeply interested in this and I
know you are as well you're a big fan of
Open Source what else do you think open
source could be applied to
or might be applied to first of all I
think people are relatively familiar
with the big individual software
projects Linux being yeah the most
well-known it's over 20 years old now
it's clearly the most
use the operating system in the world
and
what people might not know about it is
a lot of scientists believe it's the
most secure and that's kind of
counter-intuitive oh all the codes
public how could it be the most secure
but it gets beat up the most you know
because it's used the most
there's a great piece of writing an
incredible piece of writing
called the cathedral and the bazaar that
was the first kind of Magnum Opus on why
this open source thing might work and
another thing people don't get is
the cathedral in the bazaar compared are
you trying to build up like the Gowdy
church or or a Bazaar which is super
flat and wide and
obviously built by lots of people and
the thing is like open source is way
better complex problems than simple
problems and it's a very complex
problems it'd be hard for a single
company to do and so if you're building
an operating system it might have all
kinds of edges on how it integrates with
other systems you know different drivers
you might need and
the world is is able to build that
whereas an individual company would be
very difficult
and so we started to see that in MySQL
and there have been others like mongodb
and wearing one called elastic and like
there's been a lot of successful
companies around single software
Frameworks
something started happening about 10 to
15 years ago which is people started
using open source in more complex ways
and sometimes using it defensively
rather than offensively so the most
well-known is probably Android right so
Apple had come out with this Smartphone
you could only get it on ATT it scared
the [__] out of everybody not just
Google but it scared the [__] out of all
the other telcos that scared the [__]
out of all the other handset
manufacturers and so Google did this
clever thing they said oh we're going to
create a competitor but it's going to be
open source so you can trust us now
there's different versions of how open
something is and and Android is not very
open but at the time compared to the
threat of Apple it seemed like a much
better trade and so they got the world
behind them on this thing and it took
off since then that model's been been
repeated in in some esoteric ways
there's Facebook has something called
the open compute project and if you want
your Hardware to go into the
Facebook data server room it has to be
compatible with their open source
framework and what that means is
no one can
have an IP claim against Facebook
because you've basically sworn off your
IP so they're commoditizing the stuff
they're going to purchase since then 18t
and China mobile have worked with the
Linux Foundation to do the same thing
for the wireless and Wireline equipment
stack so they're defining Open Standards
for their next-gen products and if
you're a supplier that wants to sell to
them you have to agree to those
standards and once again you're you're
out of the IP game so they don't get
held up it's very clever stuff would you
mind expanding on that a little bit the
ipps well let's go to the Facebook one
because it's more understandable it's
called the open compute Foundation it's
it's managed by the Linux Foundation
acts as a steward much in the way that
the crypto world
thanks a dow manages this loose
Federation the Linux Foundation does
that Linux has been a dow for 25 years
it's super interesting and so that group
helps
they're like a non-profit
overseer of the project break ties yep
they do patent defense which I think is
super interesting so they pull patents
in no one sues within the open source
project but if someone were to come
attack it you know you'd go out after
him so anyway Facebook has all these
equipment in their data center
networking equipment storage equipment
computers software so right so they just
created this thing called the open
compute Foundation that defines Open
Standards for how all these products
work and so if you want to be on their
purchasing list you say yes we are
compatible with this open standard and
it once again it basically commoditizes
that equipment so it just gives Facebook
more leverage with a broader spectrum of
suppliers every one of these things has
a website and you can go see and so now
you know Amazon and Google they're all
part of open compute right if I'm
understanding you correctly tell me if
I'm missing something they're trying to
create conditions such that they
wouldn't end up back in the day when I
moved to Silicon Valley I worked in
storage area networking and EMC at the
time was pretty famous for kind of being
a black box like if anything broke if
anything went wrong like you need a DMC
to fix it or upgrade it and so to avoid
being held hostage or losing leverage
with suppliers
Facebook made this move is that a fair
description absolutely and then another
high profile one that's genius I mean
it's very smart oh it's super clever
Google was very afraid of Amazon running
away with the clouds Services business
in AWS and so they had a piece of
technology called kubernetes and this
was right around when Docker and
containerization took off and kubernetes
was an orchestration layer for
containers and Google decided what a
bizarre name what was it kubernetes
sounds like an Italian pasta yeah well
here's the thing though they decided
that it was in their best interest to
take this technology and gift it to an
open source Consortium they got the
Lennox Foundation to to manage it and
they went out and recruited IBM and HP
and all these other vendors to say oh
yeah we'll support kubernetes because
everyone wanted to make sure that people
weren't locked into Amazon and
eventually it got so successful that
Amazon had to announce support for
kubernetes and now if you need to move a
workload from Google to Amazon there's a
common framework for which to do that so
you're less locked in
so this seems like it's become at least
based on the examples you give I gave a
very refined reliable counter punch that
Google uses I call it defensive
corporate strategy yeah yeah and I'll
give you two more very recently well
there's always been open street maps and
that's kind of interesting because it's
data rather than you know but the open
street maps team was very kind of
non-commercial so they didn't like when
Apple and these and Google's obviously
running away with the maps business so
if you just look this up like within the
past four weeks there's a new open
source map group that's going to live on
top of open street maps that has
Facebook and
Microsoft and you know the other parties
that don't want Google to run away with
it and quite frankly I think that's
pretty cool if you talk to actually
someone you should have on it I think
that would be really cool is Jim zimlin
who's run the Linux foundation for this
whole time oh because good idea he's a
huge believer and this kind of ties into
Matt Ridley's ideas having sex that not
having IP is actually great for the
world right because it just creates
constraints for people being able to
take advantage of things and so you know
mapping's super interesting to me
because it's data oriented there's
something called risk 5 which is an open
source processor believe it or not that
has a lot of momentum now you'll see
people on the earnings calls for arms
they'll start is this a competitor is
this going to be a problem because it's
completely free license you know and
China is a big backer of Open Source and
you could understand why because the
West is accusing them of Ip theft so
this is a world where yeah you can't be
accused it's a safe space yes it's crazy
but I wonder what's possible I'll give
you some kind of grander ideas first of
all I think autonomous vehicles should
definitely be open source I think
everyone benefits safety's higher
communication layers are better like the
idea that you would use artificial
intelligence to figure out whether a
light is red yellow or green is really
[__] stupid because it's a state
machine it is in one of those three
states and that could be communicated
into the software like you you don't
need to infer that that's a known thing
but you need a Common Language your test
Suites could all be used by everyone
Academia could be working on the same
thing that the corporations are safety's
higher easier for government to get
involved if it's a single standard
and I wonder about other things like the
NIH gives out 40 billion dollars a year
and many of these projects end up as you
know research that leads to a drug that
leads to having a 17-year patent life
and gets sold at 300 Grand a year or
whatever like why wouldn't we say if you
take NIH dollars your research is open
source why do we use government dollars
to fund stuff that becomes proprietary
that doesn't make any sense to me yeah
this is something that you and I can
have a conversation about separately
yeah this is I look at the state of
nuclear energy where the costs are high
because of Regulation not because of the
actual product and I wonder what if the
globe had a standard for fission-based
nuclear reactor like wouldn't we get to
lower price points wouldn't we get to
safer products wouldn't they get more
involved it seems possible to me are
there any companies that are on a short
list of companies you would love to see
exist or types of companies like
anything that's just kind of a b in your
Bonnet or has been for
any period of time yeah I'll give you a
few so one and this one's kind of well
known in DaVinci industry but
everybody's talks about something called
the interest graph and they they wonder
why there isn't a internet website that
links everyone that is tied to a
specific interest and there are
companies that people talk about as
being close like Pinterest or quora or
Twitter you know but I don't think any
of them have really pulled it off would
Reddit fall anywhere I think specially
with some of the subreddits they're
getting close yeah you know yeah and
people talk about kind of like a Holy
Grail but there's not
anyone that's I think just
really nailed it really really nailed it
hmm and if you did you would have this
combination of really cool unlock for
people because
if you're into quilting you'd be
immediately connected with everyone else
you know that's on your level and you
can imagine that kind of thing but then
the advertising performance would just
be off the charts
yeah because you've kind of bucketed
everyone into these places I actually
think Twitter still has a huge
opportunity on this front but it have to
build a top-down version of Twitter
rather than this feed thing which is
super hard for a lot of people what do
you mean by top down I think you could
take all the information that's flowing
in Twitter and all of the influencers
that are in there and build an algorithm
that would score who's smart about
certain things
let's make it super simple to convey the
point if you look at stocks so they
already have a you idea unique
individual identifier for each stock
with the dollar symbol thing but right
now the only way you can kind of you
could do a search but there's a ton of
noise what if you had a page where for
each stock you had a list of the top
stories of the day and that could be
pulled out of the Twitter feed by
knowing which people are the ACT is on
that individual stock which you can
infer simply with the data that's
already in there you can imagine that
for sports teams so I could have Twitter
sports that is a top-down version
that's using the information in the feed
but then presents it more like a
Standard newspaper would if if you
understand what I'm getting at yeah yeah
I think I do that one's one I'm highly
interested in people feel free to reach
out in any
variation or new take on LinkedIn I just
think it kind of stopped you know and it
stopped 10 years ago one idea are you
still retired bill yeah you've got to
semi retirement
people priced you your version of
retirement is super intense yeah people
may steal this and that's okay but I
hope they reach out to me it feels to me
like you could have page rank for people
you know okay and so I don't think the
skill thing on LinkedIn works because
it's public so you get all this
performance art where people are just
you know being nice right but but what
if you had people maybe privately
opining on who they think is smartest on
particular topics you could develop a
really cool
product
that would be unique to each individual
because what you see Tim would be
different than what I see because it
starts by who you trust and yeah and
then what you see is there anyway I
think that's a really interesting
concept yeah I wonder if you know if
Twitter could actually use the literal
page rank
by correlating sort of verified accounts
all that's become kind of unusable for
me because it was kind of pay for play
for a while so it's difficult to filter
now but
if people have websites that are their
personal websites just looking at the
page rank I mean it should be it seems
like from a Computing side pretty easy
to do one thing Twitter could do that
would just be super industry is create a
a leaderboard for every topic Under the
Sun and then the things you could build
once you had that would be super
compelling yeah let's talk about Twitter
specifically a tweet thread and feel
free to amend this but I'd love to have
you walk me through this particular
thread this is from Spring of
2022 so not that long ago
and
here it goes
so there are four points under an intro
and I'll just read it if you don't mind
so an entire generation of entrepreneurs
and Tech investors built their entire
perspectives on valuation during the
second half of a 13-year amazing bull
market run the quote unquote unlearning
process could be painful surprising and
unsettling to many I anticipate denial
number one and maybe we could just do
these Point by point
we don't have to I'll do two at a time
number one previous all-time Highs are
completely irrelevant it's not quote
unquote cheap because it is down 70
percent forget those prices happen yeah
I got I screwed myself on that first one
second one valuation multiples are
always a hack proxy dangerous to use if
you insist 10x should be considered
amazing and an upper limit over that
silly so let's sit on those two for a
second would you mind just expanding on
either or both of those there's an
unfortunate reality in the Venture world
that
really became very crystal clear to me
through a conversation with Howard marks
actually but it's structurally set up
you know people talk about boom busting
Cycles but this is set up more like a
Sawtooth so risk on happens very slowly
almost like the
roller coaster
but when it crashes and if it's
interesting too I explain or do my best
job of explaining why it's structured
this way when it crashes it happens all
at once so it's more like a Sawtooth
like than a sine wave and it just
crashes and it's painful
and that just happened and it happens it
looks like it happens every seven to
fifteen years you know and I thought
this was going to happen six years ago I
even wrote some things I was way early
it took six more years and it got
ridiculously crazy but it took so long
from 09 which was the last kind of and
09 wasn't as hard to reset as o1 but
from 09 to 2013 because so many
entrepreneurs are young you know you had
people grow up that had never seen a
reset and yeah risk on is a lot like the
boiled frog like you don't know what's
happening would you mind just quickly
defining risk on for people listening
what do you mean by that so the
community
as a whole takes on more risk gradually
without realizing they're doing it and
their mental models and their Frameworks
adjust daily to what's happening and so
their
thought about how the world works is
really a window of five years or maybe
three years not 30 years yep because for
many of them they don't have the 30-year
perspective
and when the going gets good greed takes
over and you weigh the data points that
feel good to you and are going to make
you a lot of confirmation by itself like
crazy and so then you've shortened your
window to the last 12 months you know
this is how the world works and
because things got so sloppy with
interest rates being near zero
speculation so high money everywhere we
taught a lot of people not only
valuation things that will never be true
again but like
growth at all costs spend as much money
as you can you can raise money every
nine months if you want to because you
could you know the failure rate of
companies in the five years prior to
this reset is probably like the super
low probably the lowest it's ever been
failure rate of startups just because it
was so easy to raise money and so you
develop mental models and then the world
shifts dramatically 180 degrees whatever
you want to say like it couldn't be more
dramatic how fast it shifted and you
know even today entrepreneurs will say
well I just need to hold on until things
get back to normal and yeah I'm not the
only one there's other things this is
normal dude like that was a fantasy you
were in and you need to forget it fast
but you can't and there's another
painful thing that I don't even just
about because it creates real problems
and it's actually quite unfortunate but
Founders whatever that Peak valuation is
they ran the math where they took their
ownership they most applied it by that
number and they thought about their net
worth that way and that can just be
super destructive like once it's no
longer true you mean psychologically
psychologically yeah I think it's super
difficult to come to terms with once
you've been through that
what do you mean by valuation multiples
are always a hack proxy
so this gets into some of the earlier
stuff we talked about just about how
deep you go on investing history and
understanding investors but if there is
a scale of financial sophistication
between one and ten and you would say a
really smart person in New York is a
eight and a half the average Silicon
Valley person on financial literacy is a
two
and it's funny because they make fun of
Wall Street but it's just out of
ignorance they don't yeah know anything
and so most of them think about
valuation by a price to revenue multiple
which couldn't be a cruder
tool and at one point I wrote a blog
post called the keys to the 10x Revenue
club and I took all the public tech
stocks and laid them into end based on
price to revenue and one of them was at
20 and one of them was at point one and
it was just a big curve so there's no
line there there's no reason to believe
that that price to revenue is how you
should value anything but just because
it's easy and these companies are young
and immature it's hard to do a DCF it's
hard to do something more sophisticated
it's the common language of the group
but things changed overnight and so
someone was was pointing out I think on
Twitter that and they use price to gross
margin instead of price for Revenue
still twilio went from 70 times gross
margin to three
it's like in a very short window I mean
talk about valuation reset that is just
radical and so
that
shakes the industry yeah and no one's
going to feel sorry for Silicon Valley
and I'm not trying to elicit empathy but
just in terms of understanding what
happens it is so
foundational the change is so radical
that the best thing you can possibly
happen is if you can adjust your mental
models fast and get on with the new
world but it's very hard for people to
do and I write that this kind of stuff
in part to help the industry and I'm you
know I'm super grateful Sequoia in 09
put out there's a famous deck they put
out so long good times or something like
that and these things help people adjust
faster yeah having mental models having
structure having smart people tell them
it's okay it gets them there faster
that I think relates to number three and
you mentioned DCF just for people who
don't have that reference uh discounted
cash flow so number three is you may be
shocked to learn that people want to
value your company on
FCF
that's free cash flow am I getting that
right yeah yep and earnings Facebook
trades at 14 times Gap EPS am I
pronouncing that correctly yes yes and
is growing 23 what earnings multiple are
you assuming question mark so could you
just walk us through that bullet yeah
you know I'm gonna use a little bit of
detail so you can understand but like
the point I am that best of two on the
financial literacy if you think all
companies should trade it like 10 times
Revenue here's one of the most
successful companies of all time that is
producing massive amounts of positive
cash flow and GAP audited earnings
that's trading at a very low multiple of
those Gap earnings and earnings are a
small percentage of your Revenue right
so if you're right trading at 10 times
Revenue you're probably trading at 50
times earnings right and here they're
trading at 14. or you may not even have
earnings because most there's a great
graph as we should try and find it one
so someone can see length of the
percentage of companies at IPO that are
profitable and it's this nice cyclical
wave that goes with these boom bus
Cycles we'll find it and put it in the
show notes so Wall Street does risk on
also right and so
in really dark times the percentage of
companies IPO and their profitable is
like 90 but by 2020 2021 that number is
five percent like the vast majority of
companies are losing money as they go
public and wall Street's encouraging
that behavior and so I've often said
DaVinci Wall Street is the buyer of what
Venture Capital produces and if Wall
Street wants high growth money losing
businesses we will create as many as
they can possibly consume because those
are a lot easier to build than the
profitable ones way easier yeah that's
part of why you end up in this cycle
thing the point of highlighting that is
just to try and get entrepreneurs and
founders
reset on where the world is today and
where valuations are why did you and I'm
sure a lot of people listening will
think this is a stupid question because
they already know the answer but why did
you highlight Facebook and the way that
you highlighted Facebook just because on
a historical basis Facebook is trading
at a very low multiple it looks like a
very cheap stock I mean Coca-Cola you
know for years traded at 30 35 times
earnings Facebook said 14 are meta
whatever they like to be called yeah
and 23 is a pretty impressive growth
rate for a company of this season yeah
right for sure like Coke is less than 10
growth like five or three yeah since
imagine meta what do you think of I mean
on one level I really have to admire
that just doubling down on the metaverse
what is your take on this sort of
Direction so years ago you know I read
snow crash when it came out oh so good I
thought it was the best thing that I had
ever consumed and I'm I was in Hook Line
and Sinker and so when Philip Rosedale
started second life I was knocking on
his door I served on that board for 12
years I have immense knowledge
on this kind of immersive stuff and
Philip and I actually did a post-mortem
podcast recently which is I would Point
people too cool but what we found is I
think there's a difference between the
kind of gaming stuff and this idea that
people want to
live experiences like they do in the
real world in this virtual world and
what we learned in that second category
you know I see this in the Facebook
demos and stuff like oh we're going to
do a board meeting in world or whatever
is yeah that that doesn't make a lot of
sense
the number of people that love escapism
first of all young people do like yeah
you don't want to wait in line at the
postal office in your second life right
did young people do it they role play a
lot yeah and so yeah that makes sense
and then a handful of adults do it they
they have wooden swords in the park or
burning man is that experience sure but
it's not a high percentage of humans and
one thing we found is quite
interestingly is a lot of the people
that love it are looking for an escape
so they may actually have mental health
problems or they're in a tough spot in
their life and it reminds you that both
snow crash and Ready Player One were
dystopian novels right yeah people were
escaping a world that sucked and so
we did a bunch in World board meetings
there I mean and this is pre-zoom like
Zoom is an amazing substitute which is
one of the Frameworks from competitive
strategy like to the notion of being in
world and so it got even harder right
because Zoom I think zoom's way better
for a board meeting than making everyone
get an avatar and sitting around it like
I just don't think that's gonna happen
so it's a long answer but I think the
premise they have is wrong I don't think
this becomes the next platform the next
smartphone I just I don't see that so
how do you reconcile that with the
position that they're Trading
cheaply I guess if that's just based on
the math Wall Street on my side on this
one I think if they shut down the VR
effort not only will the profitability
would soar because they're spending real
money like five to ten billion a year
but I think the stock doubles doubles
hmm
yeah where would you suggest they
redirect their resources
for this because people are saying it
all over Twitter there's really good
buzz on some of their AI tools
and the world's super excited about that
yes they are my God you look at uh open
Ai and the Microsoft investment and so
on I mean it's incredible longer
conversation but I think WhatsApp has
some interesting things going on could
you give a teaser if you read about
what's up in India it has a similar
place in the world that tencent with
WeChat does in China like they've
accomplished more
so those things are more interesting to
me yeah so I'm curious you know I've had
Mark Zuckerberg on the podcast and
the ease about a strong conviction I'm
curious from your perspective like zero
to a hundred percent where would you put
the likelihood that he would ever
can the VR efforts and redirect
resources it's funny a lot of people
love to discuss this and there's a bias
like when you get pot committed to me
that's confirmation bias too but like
you if you've already bought something
you like it way more than yeah sunk cost
fallacy yeah it's super hard and he's
had people telling him what I just said
for two years now so yeah it's
interesting because if you look at other
big bets like that
I think the two most amazing are AWS and
Android like they were both kind of
out of left field not part of their core
business but super successful and I just
I think
you've already run the clock
you've already spent way more than
either of those did in the development
of those things and yeah you just don't
have the number someone was there was a
thing going around Twitter that the
year-over-year sales of headsets is down
globally for the industry like that's
just it's not happening
all right let's hop to number four so
revenue and earnings quality matter
could you
please explain the word quality yeah
it's interesting that's like a Nuance
thing like if you talk to someone who'd
been investing on Wall Street for for 15
years you could talk about revenue or
earnings quality and they would they
would know exactly what you were talking
about but it's not something the average
person would know and if that blog post
again that I wrote called
the keys to the 10x Revenue Club I go
through like 12 different things that
signify quality but and we'll link to
that in the show notes yeah so I mean a
simple one is margins like if you are
reselling used cars and your revenue is
the price of the cars you're selling but
you're only making 10 on a car that's
really low Revenue quality compared to a
SAS vendor with 90 gross margins their
incremental dollar of Revenue creates 90
cents of gross margin yours creates
seven cents a gross margin you can't
value those companies both on price to
revenue like they're very different yeah
so that would be Revenue quality
earnings qualities typically relates to
cash flow so you might have really good
Gap earnings but because of different
factors in your business your your cash
flows may not be nearly as good it could
be timing differences those kind of
things but you know anyway you go
through the posts that I wrote but
they're just elements of you know
whether or not you have a competitive
Advantage whether or not you have churn
in your business like is this customer
going to stay around forever or they
might leave tomorrow one of the reasons
Coca-Cola trades at a high multiple is
everyone imagines Coke will still be
here 50 years from now they have no
reason not to believe that yep whereas
some of these tech companies you know
why is Facebook at 14 they don't know
yeah could Tick Tock take away their
business and then they're done overnight
those become bigger risks for tech
companies sometimes because they look
like they might be disruptible
you mentioned and you also write about
and speak about competitive Advantage a
lot what are some lesser known or
undervalued competitive advantages I
mean we already talked about Network
effect like that's one that just comes
to mind right away lock-in we had hinted
at is there reasons why switching costs
which is also you know back in it's in
the porter book like are there switching
costs that make it hard to leave for a
customer to leave you know how many
substitutes are there for your product
how unique is it right that's a
competitive Advantage like are you an N
of one and some of the network effect
companies become that way like I could
create an Instagram competitor but I
don't have everyone on it so the user
experience is a function of everyone
being on it so it's hard right to
compete with that thing so you have you
have a strong competitive Advantage it
could be performance like in an
Enterprise product you know you look at
something like snowflake people you know
just say this database does things no
other database will do and so then that
becomes a competitive Advantage how hard
is it for someone to find an alternative
to you and trade you is an easy way of
saying it this is not directly related
to competitive Advantage but I wanted to
just revisit the total addressable
market and your OpenTable story with
this with the spreadsheet or the model
that had been
capped at 17 and you're like we're going
to 99 it's not 70 percent
just to reflect back also on
Uber since you and I were both along for
that right uh pun intended and in the
early days you know there are three
black cars two or three black cars in
the very very early days sort of
prototyping
and I remember
sitting with Garrett and looking at some
of the
potential Market sizes but the
Assumption always was that the pie
could grow and should grow if Uber is
functioning effectively and that's what
ended up happening so you can't say you
know there are 700 black cars in San
Francisco what percentage of those will
use Uber and the the upper limit is 700
because then in the matter of a handful
of years you have a thousand plus yeah
black cars because of the rider demand
so
I just wanted to to mention that since
you you also mentioned it earlier yeah I
wrote a very long piece on this because
there's a famous I think NYU professor
aswath
is his last name's not coming to me
right now but he's famous for evaluation
work he's always on CNBC and he he wrote
a piece that said Uber wouldn't be worth
more than I don't know if it was two or
three billion dollars and I wrote a
reply called how to miss by a mile
oswath dhamadharan I believe yeah it is
wonderful I called him before I
published it just because I like
to tell him it was coming but it was a
classic mistake he basically took the
taxi market and said that's the upper
limit yep and that's just the wrong math
like Travis and the team made this thing
so convenient and so available that it
was a product that's 10x better than the
taxi market and so the usage yeah and I
by the time I wrote that I already knew
that Uber in San Francisco was 20x
bigger than the taxi market in San
Francisco yeah so I already knew he was
wrong with that analysis we'd already
blown through it yeah but he didn't know
that and so yeah and I mentioned in that
article there's a a couple of classic
examples of this there's one where
Mackenzie was hired to calculate the
global market for mobile phones and got
came back with nine hundred thousand is
the upper limit and I have found you get
into more trouble with this kind of Tam
conservatism then like it hurts you more
than helps you as an investor if you
feel like something super disruptive and
it's unlocking things like your
optionality to build on top of that is
going to be pretty special yeah and so
yeah it makes me think of Esports versus
any comparable you might use with I
don't know live viewership of sports or
whatever it's just not
this is not the same thing
so
that was the one through four points
Jeff Bezos I think retweeted or replied
to that tweet thread
and was very complimentary
you have spent time with Jeff what do
you think are some of the most under
appreciated aspects
related to Jeff in any capacity
he's probably the best entrepreneur that
I've ever been around or got to know
like
it's remarkable yeah and it's
multifaceted here's one that I think is
not well discussed so he has a bunch of
traits that make him a great
entrepreneur
the company today is it's such a radical
scale
that there's no way and he's not and
he's in the chairman role like he's not
touching all the decisions he's not
touching all the product decisions all
like he has built a organizational
framework to take what Jeff Bezos
believes and run the whole company that
way and that's not well dissected not
well understood
here's a great story I'm riding in an
Uber this is about eight years ago maybe
seven and I always talk to them I always
talk to the drivers because I'm a
shareholder and I always talk to the
driver and I'm asking him you know
something about whether we can stop he
goes well I got to get back down to San
Jose by 2 30. I'm like what happens at 2
30 he goes I have to meet at the Amazon
warehouse at 2 30. I go what's going on
he goes oh they got this new program
they're running where
you show up at 2 30 and they have all
these burner phones and they load your
car with packages and give you a
manifest and then they booked a ride
over Uber and so this was the early days
of same-day delivery yeah that's cool
this is a company that's worth 100
billions of dollars that is running an
experiment on top of uber and yeah I
know for a fact that most of the
companies I've worked with that have
gotten over 20 or 30 million in Revenue
would not run that experiment because
someone would say oh we won't know how
to do the accounting we can't like
that's too much of a hack like whatever
but this large company was super
comfortable running this kind of hack
experiment on this other company yeah
and he showed me the Manifest I looked
at all this stuff of course I called
Uber immediately thereafter and briefed
them that we're being used in this way
but unbelievable right I mean just
unbelievable no other large company
would do that project none zero and so
somehow he's in institutionalized this
kind of experimentation and risk seeking
and he's talked about it there's a great
interview with him from code that you
should try and find for the show notes
from four or five years ago and I could
watch it over and over and over it's
like the eagles documentary I could just
watch it again that'd be okay but it's
fascinating they ask him when does a
internal experiment get killed and he
said when the last person with good
judgment gives up
and that's not how other big companies
work they don't run experiments that way
in fact one of the reasons startups can
compete with big companies is because
most big company experiments they run
one test and if it fails they quit and a
startup can't quit because they have to
shut down if they quit so they run
experiment one and two and three and
four and five and then they pivot and do
six and seven and eight and they stay up
all night because it has to work and so
they just get way more shots on gold
than the big companies do
yeah Bezos is also someone is chronicled
a lot of his thinking and
decision-making Frameworks in letters to
shareholders and there there are some
compilations of his letters much like
Warren Buffett yeah they're very good
and and they're very good I mean just
the
to give one example I mean it could be
highly tactical so I mean the reason
that
people who would call internal meetings
would be required to put together I
think it was a six-page document in the
first 30 minutes of the meeting would be
spent reading this meticulous document
and all the reasons for why that was
instituted I mean it's very concrete
it's not
sort of ambiguous
hand wavy stuff so I definitely
recommend people check that out and also
by the way net mirrors back what we
talked about earlier about riding and
and thought process like if you're
forced to write a six page paper it's
much
harder to put that together than it is a
five yeah page PowerPoint
it's easier to leave stuff out like you
really have to think through everything
yeah he's also super curious like beyond
belief
he's willing to change his priors
you know super fast if you got something
wrong
yeah it's something else I mean I think
AWS is maybe top five business move in
the history of the world
um yeah just the notion that they
launched that out of a consumer internet
company and became one of the most
important Enterprise companies it's
fairly unprecedented it's just amazing
it is jaw-dropping and for people who
want a an Easter egg if you have not
learned of this before go to
relentless.com and see what happens it
will forward directly to amazon.com
that is not accidental
so is there anything else that you'd
like to say about
the recent events and sort of Correction
slash implosion or do you feel like
you've said what you would like to say
on that is there anything there's one
last comment I would make it's
interesting I was listening the other
day to a podcast with Shane Battier who
I've been fortunate enough to meet I
don't know who that is oh he was
famously outlined by Michael Lewis's the
no stat All-Star in the New York Times
magazine he's an NBA player really
successful got it that kind of rode the
analytics craze and did things that most
people don't do but when you ran all the
numbers like he's always winning and
that kind of thing he played at Duke and
and has a ring you know from
the NBA and anyway he's now starting to
dip his toe into the corporate world and
so he did this podcast kind of a
crossover but he's he was talking about
shashesky and Hal shashesky you know he
spent four years there and and so he had
a lot of stories but I was listening and
nodding because you know you've had
great coaches on right you've had great
players on that have played for great
coaches and these these learnings can be
translated right and so he's saying oh
you know Coach K told us that he
expected to very much out of us each
individual had to perform at their
highest level he said it's always team
first if you need to be an individual
you don't need to be here and Shane was
talking about how people remember the
winners more than they remember whether
you were the third or fourth scorer on a
team like they remember the winners and
I think that's true in in startup world
as well and then he said there's a
singular goal for this organization and
it's to win the national championship
and like those three tenants you know
he's talking about relatives to Coach K
and I'm like in the middle of nodding
and I was writing stuff down I'm like oh
I'll go talk to people I'll go forward
this podcast and then I stop call old
and I realized
in 2020 2021 if an internet entrepreneur
stood up and said those things out loud
about what he wanted from his company he
might get canceled like company first
you know you have to perform at your
absolute best and the only goal here is
the one goals you know the corporation
we're all on a team together we wandered
to a place that's very different than
that and on your recent podcast with
Jonathan hate he started to talk about I
think you were using the word
anti-fragility but how this had crossed
over from the campus world and these
people were now these younger rights I
was asking him how to develop
intellectual anti-fragility and he was
giving the counter example of what we've
observed right it's happened in the
university and this did get out into the
companies and so these companies were
being basically held accountable for
delivering an experience for the
individual it's like your goal is to
company is to help the individual have a
great life and I think it's very hard to
be high performing imagine if Coach K
had that problem like he had to make
everyone make sure everyone on the team
felt happy and safe included and that
was true north it would be very hard for
him to be performing I don't think he'd
want to coach yeah and we've lived
through a little bit of a reaction to
this so Brian Armstrong at coinbase
has very publicly spoken I think Toby
at Shopify took a little more nuanced
stance but the same stance that we have
one objective here which is this company
and if you're hyper passionate about
something else that you got to talk
about it all the time with this company
maybe you should go do that full time
but this performance awareness had kind
of gone away because of everything I
talked about it was so easy to survive
as a company and now we're in a world
where I think you know you got to make
hard choices you gotta do what's right
you got to perform and so it'll be
interesting to see whether someone can
act in this way without without getting
negative and Brian took a lot of heat
for what he did yeah it seems to have
passed pretty quickly I mean he was able
to weather the storm and take the heat
but it was pretty short-lived when I
talked to Executives at the bigger
companies are the ones we all know
they're dealing with this stuff on a
daily basis non-stop Non-Stop and it's
very similar to what's happening at the
University level and so it's just super
curious to me I played Sports in high
school and college and when there's a
winning team and the coach writes a book
I've always ran out and read it and like
made it part of my mental model so it
was kind of interesting to see where we
are
what do you think the future of and this
may not be you tell me if this is a
a question with some there there or not
but what do you think the future of
e-commerce looks like and since you
mentioned Toby I'm a huge fan of Toby I
mean I was an advisor to Shopify super
early when they had about 10 employees
and I just think he's one of the most
incredible humans out there
but where do you think Shopify fits in
or doesn't fit into that it seems like
with some of the Apple privacy changes
and all these various things the
landscape has changed super dramatically
you know if you try to look into your
Experience slash crystal ball to look
forward at what e-commerce looks like
well one I'm a huge Toby fan too and at
the end of this I'll tell a quick Toby
story that I think is yeah oh wonderful
tool that people can use and he he gave
me permission to share it so I thought
what they did
with the shop app was super cool so the
previous Christmas I started noticing
websites I'd never been to before knew
who I was and allowed one-click checkout
and very few companies can make their
business as a B2B company and then have
this crossover product which has a
consumer Network effect and and they did
that with that app and I thought it was
just super cool
that they pulled that off and so look he
is
one of the truly greats and you've
interviewed enough of these people like
when you're with a Bezos or Toby you
kind of know it right yeah it's
different and Toby's been on the podcast
I recommend people check it out yeah
it's just a different feeling yeah and
they're hyper curious they have their
own mental models they're willing to
learn new ones they're constantly
thinking
and they've built some type of
organizational fabric that's scaling
which is another element here's the one
he shared which is one of my favorite
ever so he said whenever we're dealing
with a problem and we call a meeting to
talk about the problem I always start
with this structure
we are here to solve a problem so the
one option that we know we're not going
to leave the room
doing is the status quo that is off the
table so whenever we finish this meeting
I want to talk about what option we're
taking but it's not going to be what
we're currently doing and I think that
is brilliant because most of the
companies that I've ever worked with
their default is well let's not change
it if we can't get the gumption to
change something don't mess with it and
they thought it was genius
I just thought it was genius
he's also not only a incredibly smart
effective
human and
leader but I'm very humble and yeah
I really just admire him so deeply not
just for the performance of the company
but for how he carries himself in the
world I think it's it's just as
impressive to me that he carries that
much horsepower but doesn't wield it in
a overbearing
way which would be very easy to do a lot
of people do it
so I agree thank you Toby
so just a few more questions Bill and uh
if this goes nowhere I'll take the blame
for it so aside from the books that you
have mentioned are there any books that
you have gifted frequently to other
people
yes there's three books I would mention
so the first one that I've gifted the
most is
called complexity by Mitchell Waldrop
which is about the rise of the Santa Fe
Institute and
you know even when you were talking with
hate I think he mentioned you know
certain things are complex adaptive
systems they're very hard to predict
they're very hard to analyze they're
very hard to understand and that's what
Santa Fe is all about that book
introduced me to network effects when I
get to go there I usually go a couple
times a year and Mike Moses there and
like and Josh Wolf's there from loxton I
just love the learning of things I don't
know and just like pushing my brain to
go farther than I would with the normal
stuff I consume
and it's beautifully written great
writer Mr Waldron
there's a book that I happen to have
right here this book Mr China is
fantastic he went to China in the mid
90s and started a fund to privatize a
bunch of Industries he's from London and
got his head handed to him and survived
enough to write a humorous story about
it but holy [__] you know it sounds kind
of like the red notice by Bill Browder
equivalent but in China his life didn't
end up getting threatened he did go to
jail but like yeah it was I read red
notice also there's no death involved
this is more of a business book and a
know what you don't know and what can
happen to you when you go into you know
foreign lands yes
and in the book that I've been
fascinated with the past five years four
or five years is Epstein's range David
Epstein wrote a book called Reigns which
was kind of a counter punch to the 10
000 hour Thing by Malcolm Gladwell and
it started by talking about Federer but
at the end of it he got into
a couple of Notions that I find super
interesting so a lot of the big
breakthroughs in science have come from
people that have changed disciplines or
changed genres which he talks about a
lot which I just find super fascinating
like if you go on Twitter which
obviously there's a lot of people
shouting but you're constant refrain
it's like shut up you don't know
anything about this field leave it to
the people in the field but yeah but if
you study Science and History that's not
actually the biggest breakthroughs come
from people that that had a different
middle framework and move over and then
see things differently and so I just I
think it's super interesting there's a
professor at UCLA named Hollybrook who
did a piece on something he calls far
analogies where
he views it as an intellectual skill but
who can borrow ideas from farther away
than where they are like listen to some
podcast of this person in this field and
have an impact what they do and I I just
I I'm fascinated by everything in that
world
it's a range for people who want a
little bit more the subtitle is why
generalists Triumph in a specialized
world and I I did recognize the name
because of
another book which is the sports Gene
yeah
extraordinary athletic performance which
is which is a great book the Santa Fe
Institute let's talk about just for a
second or maybe a minute or maybe more
than a few minutes why is that important
I mean you've I suppose explained it in
part and what if you gleaned from your
involvement
because it seems like such a prominent
commitment on your part yeah another
individual that's been involved there
for a long time and has has been the
biggest benefactor is a guy named Bill
Miller who was a very famous Wall Street
investor had one of the he was at leg
Mason and had a 15-year run where he'd
beat the s p and
I think for Michael and Bill and myself
and Joshua
we
by listening and learning about
analysis of these types of systems and
seeing professors from all the another
big thing about Santa Fe is that it's
multi-disciplinary so they have
biologists hanging around with
epidemiologists hanging around with
physicists you know and they all
interact together and Cormac McCarthy
hangs out there too which is kind of
cool but
yeah that is cool and just hearing and
learning you pick up things like the
network effect thing I picked up the
first time I went there with Brian
Arthur and I applied that quite directly
but there's other little things there
was a speech that was given three or
four years ago about the electric grid
problems that were happening in North
America and the professor that presented
it at the end said the best solution is
smaller communities that are Loosely
coupled and that isn't really
interesting you could use that framework
like I walked up to her afterwards I
said you just explain why the euro is a
bad idea because you tightly coupled
this thing too much and you can just
imagine even like a computer system
that's distributed that learning could
have other applications if it's too
distributed there's no scale but if it's
hyper integrated then you have this
failure problem this Global failure
problem right so anyway
it's kind of a an example do they have
talks and so on online or is it more
online you can see published books
there's lots of stuff online it's cool
okay so the last one or two questions
this one can go any number of directions
but if you could put anything on a
billboard this is metaphorically
speaking just to get a message a
question a prompt suggestion
image anything out to billions of people
you know just let's just assume they
would all understand it
what might you put
on that billboard I think Circa 2023 and
everything that's happened over the past
five or six years I would put be less
tribal
be less tribal and I have friends on
both sides of the political spectrum and
I can't
imagine an activity that turns off more
brain cells than tribal affiliation like
all the books that have been written on
bias and all the you know condiment into
Cassie and like thinking fast and slow
and all the Nobel prizes for that stuff
I think political bias is stronger than
confirmation by sunk cost all those
things and people are just turning off
their brains and it's both directions
and it's not just the Friends it's not
just the populace like it's people that
just affiliate and then they don't think
they don't listen And It's both sides I
mean I'll give you an example
gerrymandering horrible they both do it
it's horrible like just say it's
horrible but they don't they say oh look
those guys are horrible when they do it
capture is horrible and on the
Republican side that's Banks and big
Pharma but on the on the other side
Credit Unions the teachers union and the
police Union George Floyd certainly
doesn't happen if the police union
doesn't have the power they did because
Derek shopping would have been off the
force but but the police Union protected
him and if you're on the left you can't
say that you can't make that statement
you can't be anti-union and it's just
stupid like for people to turn their
brains off this much
anyway I'm passionate about this yeah so
how would you suggest let's just say you
were teaching
you're a good teacher and you've you've
spoken to students
if you were to give a presentation on
cultivating anti-tribalism probably have
a sexier deadline to it but what might
that lecture or class contain or blog
post I think the first thing I would try
and do is just highlight the fact that
people are turning off their brains the
way that people have proven how
confirmation bias Works how loss
aversion works like there's 20 different
cognitive biases that we're all aware of
so the first thing I would do is just
run some there have been stuff done like
and then I would just highlight like why
does anyone want to be intellectually
inconsistent if you think it's an ends
to a means then you're just in a fight
you're just in a fight like I don't even
want to have a discussion with someone
if
cheating on your spouse and
philanderings okay when your side
doesn't but it's oh horrible when the
other side does it what's your principle
like I don't understand and so I try and
get people in touch with the fact that
they're doing it and then I would just
highlight that our government's far from
perfect and so
most tribal people view their side as
near perfect and there's no sign of that
anywhere
um
by the way there are a few orgs that I'm
starting to learn about non-profits that
like give money to Centrist candidates
things like that
and I think the world if you could go
back 30 years it was just more collegial
yeah like across the aisle I mean you
mentioned Twitter a number of times I
feel like
Twitter incentivizes for polarization
just with the mechanisms at work and
you're a good writer I wonder
why you post so much on Twitter
which seems so impermanent compared to a
blog post just the durability of the
signal seems to wane so quickly
why do you now post more
of your thoughts to Twitter say than in
longer form
probably because I'm old and I don't
have the concentration that I used to
have to get to work done so two you
brought two subjects I'll answer the
second part first and then we talk about
the tribal stuff too
I find Twitter just to be super
fascinating as like your ability to get
close to experts leaders in your field
100 greatest it's unbelievable more so
than LinkedIn and there's a chance that
some reply you give to them they might
like or they might follow you and now
you've developed a mentor or a peer
partner like it's really just shocking
amazing the amount of information you
can take out of this thing if you use it
I'd say a third of my podcast guests
come from Twitter interactions and then
DM oh yeah and that's I mean that's
something you and I may feel that most
people don't know but if you develop a
massive following DM becomes this
magical place where yeah about half the
time someone asked me if I can help them
recruit someone that person follows me
so now I can just start talking to him
you know right out of the gate there's a
protection too for high AI profile
people in DM because there's no personal
information that is exchanged right and
they can always block you if they get
sick of you and therein lies the safety
so you can also if you're trying to
interact and I don't do that that much
but interact with say A-list celebrities
it's like okay you can try to Wade
through this Phalanx of like agents and
managers and publicists and just takes
two years to try to get a message to
someone or you can just DM them if if
that gate is open there's a book idea
that I'm working on and one of my core
beliefs is that in this day and age
circuit 2023 your ability to rise up in
any industry or any particular
Endeavor is so much easier than it ever
was before because your ability to get
close to the mentors leaders best
practitioners and learn from them is
unlike it's ever ever been before and
add in hybrid work I mean maybe you can
work for a company that's not even near
you like it's really awesome for people
that want to pull themselves up on the
tribal thing you and hate went deep on
this and he's way Smarter on it than me
but it does reinforce performance you
know and
it's too bad
yeah let's double click on performance
so
recent conversation with James clear and
I'm going to paraphrase him but he said
who you are and the decisions you make
or Downstream of the information you
consume in a sense so you should choose
your sources of information very
carefully and uh I would tend to agree
with that I'm pretty selective
are there any newsletters newsletters
you subscribe to or read regularly or
writers you follow regularly not in book
form but in more frequent form yeah Eric
newcomer does a venture capital sub
stack and so just being in the industry
that's something to follow
there's a website called Tech meme yeah
where Gabe has this curated news rank
including Twitter comments people have
made about that article it's just it's a
daily oh that's cool I haven't seen that
integrated that's pretty cool it's great
machine yeah it's really well done so in
the industry like
I go there and between Tech Meme and
Twitter I end up on a lot of sub stacks
and whatnot but I don't have one where I
read every single thing they post like
I've inverted
everything's been inverted into this
consumption world where the aggregator
of Twitter or Tech meme is kind of
funneling what I find and then and then
I go do those things one of the things I
think Twitter should do is Define a
long-form bucket container a podcast
container and a video container and then
have pocket-like features where if you
see something like that you store it and
then it cues I mean that's one of the
benefits of Spotify as a podcast
listener is I I think it cues and
organizes easier than some of the others
yeah for sure but I discovered things
that way
if there's anything more you want to say
about the book or do you want to keep
that
Under Wraps largely for now is there
anything else you'd like to say about
the work in progress there's a speech I
gave at the University of Texas that you
could put in the show notes because it's
out there and and it's talking about
chasing your dream job and how to
succeed and Thrive at your dream job and
I've done some research since I gave the
speech because people have encouraged me
to turn it into a book and
some of the polling we've done shows 70
percent of people have career regret
seventy percent which is a huge number
and so we're doing some more work to
better understand that and how people
end up in that place
but the punch line which I hinted at
earlier is I just don't think there's
ever been a better time to have a
self-determined
job process if you want
and the tools are better than they've
ever been and there's way more detail in
this thing but it it was built off of
studying the biography of a very unusual
set of people Bobby Knight Bob Dylan and
Danny Meyer the restaurant tour and
seeing similar patterns in how they
attacked what they did
it's not a curiosity if you were invited
to give and agreed to give a TED talk
but you couldn't give it on Venture
Capital couldn't do investing
couldn't do career advice
what might you give your Ted Talk on
probably regulatory capture okay I have
this core belief that capitalism and
democracy who eventually destroy one
another could you also just Define
regulatory capture at some point you
don't have to do it right now yeah I do
I mean there's a Wikipedia entry for it
just the basics for folks but there's a
famous Professor from Chicago and I
forget his name like 1958 that wrote
this seminal report but basically in a
heavily regulated industry the
incumbents typically end up being the
ones that write the legislation and
typically lock themselves in build
competitive Advantage build a moat back
to Michael Porter through the use of
legislation and make it harder for
startups to break in
one of my favorite examples the Obama
Administration came up with this program
where they spent 44 billion dollars
paying doctors to implement EHR system
and the idea that you would pay someone
to implement software when you need to
do it on your own for your own
competitive survival but there was a
healthcare Advisory Board the CEO of
epic sat on that board and they came up
with this program but what is epic it's
the leading provider of software yeah
exactly it's not but like once they came
up with this program the thing that you
would obviously think is well what's
wrong with paying someone to to use
software well they probably won't use it
so then they put up like another 20
billion for for the second phase called
meaningful use where if you proved you
were using the software you got paid to
implement you get another check and it's
just it's mind-numbing and this stuff is
everywhere in our government like I said
both sides of the aisle everywhere and
you know citizens united did not help it
it made it way worse and
our government would be way better if
you could somehow extract these powers
from the government
so if you could wave a magic wand and
get some things moving to
act as some countervailing Force
to reduce regulatory capture what would
you do and by the way we have really
broken Industries with the the most
regulated Pharma
banks telcos these are the ones I mean
like look at the banks you know five
other industrialized nations have moved
to insta transfer run by the government
between banks in the UK it's called UK
faster payments it happened 17 years ago
you can read the Wikipedia page on it
ACH In America still takes three days to
clear it's [__] ridiculous but it's
because the banks and Visa have too much
power with the financial services
committee and they've prevented Powell
wants to do it it's called fed now it's
been on the books for 10 years like but
they block it because of how we operate
the first thing you would do and no one
will agree to it is your reverse
citizens united there's too much money
in the system you can go to open Secrets
I think it is on almost any one of these
decisions and you'll see like you can
just watch the financial service
committee someone argues against fed now
and then you look them up and there's a
big Bank in their region and that big
bank's the donor like it's not rocket
science but that's where I'd start with
some kind of Reform you know one of my
first experiences as a this would be
definitely be my TED Talk one of my
first companies I worked on that had a
potential regulatory hurdle
a lawyer told me oh well you should talk
to these congressmen or whatever and so
did you want me to introduce you sure
and and so oh there's gonna get a phone
call he's going to be in your
neighborhood can you get a bunch of
people in a conference room like what do
you mean a bunch of people I just wanted
to say hello no I need you to get 15
people in the conference room I go why
he goes and they all need to bring the
maximum check that they can donate and
I'm like really so so I'd call a few
people I I felt horrible like oh yeah
you got to give 10 grand I just want to
talk to this guy and then and then a
week before they show up they go you
know your spouse can give too tell
everyone their spouse can give and so
this happened to me three times three
times to meet someone in Washington so
dirty 100 Grand together like just to
just stay at the first meeting and that
that's real that's a great speaking fee
yeah no that's how it works and so I
don't know you look at things like the
Health Care System they're just so
messed up you know it's not a free
market and it's not single-payer it's
it's the worst of both and it's the best
one either
so if democracy and capitalism are on
this
Annihilation crash course I mean what do
you think uh I I know this is look we're
talking about very complex systems yeah
and all sorts of uh you know tertiary
effects as to who the hell knows but
what do you think the U.S looks like in
10 or 20 years
and conversely are there any countries
I mean despite their current situation
that some people hold them against I
think the UK which is much older than us
you know has done a better job than we
have one thing they have with what just
for clarity what have they done a better
job with I think less regulatory capture
yep and one particular thing they have
that is super clever and will cause
every lawyer in the world to hate me
they have something called losing party
pays oh yes absolutely I I'm astonished
that the US functions the way it does
but yeah please continue so we live in
the United States of litigation and a
lot of the friction that exists that
slows down the gears and messes things
up is because of the Vigilante nature of
our legal system
and losing party Pace just makes
the number of initial litigations filed
dropped by 10x
yeah
losing party pays yeah and I mean
does the UK allow its barristers to have
contingency fees or
they must have something I don't know if
upper limit on that that is much lower
than the US before I give my TED talk
I'll go a little deeper
all right regulatory capture
bills there anything else you'd like to
say any closing comments uh
recommendations anything you'd like to
point my audience to or ask them to do
anything that comes to mind at all you'd
like to mention before we wind to a
close I think I'm good man I think we
hit on a lot of different things yeah we
did we covered a lot and uh thank you
for the time Bill I really appreciate it
this is great and for everybody
listening we will put together extensive
show notes linking to everything we
talked about and you can find that as
usual at tim.blog podcast
and until next time be just a bit Kinder
than as necessary and experiment
experiment experiment thanks for tuning
in